леопард готується до атаки очікувалося
що ці танки мають стати вирішальними для
контернаступу України який триває
безперервно вже понад три місяці
леопард - це хижак і Ну так як ми
працюємо вночі то нічний Хижак Артем
водій і Механік танка мобілізований рік
тому він починав воювати на старому
радянському танку на противагу якому
леопард каже військовий має багато
переваг в нього є
швидкість тобто за рахунок цього я знаю
що
в екстремальній ситуації я зможу швидко
зробити свою роботу швидко ну если це
потрібно відійти є Все це потрібно
швидко під'їхати тобто в цьому перевага
цього танку якщо зрівнювати з нашими
танками якщо по нам ведеться вогонь Ми
його ми це бачимо нам це докладаючи
перевага даної машини в тому що ми
можемо швидко швидко переміщуватись на
ній ну це велика перевага Вони не тільки
швидкі леопарди розвиваючи швидкість
понад 70 кілометрів за годину ще на
Сумщині приладами нічного бачення та
оптикою чим значно перевершують ворожі
командир Ігор розповідає нам що леопарди
з його роти знищили набагато більше
ворожих танків ніж могли з тими що були
раніше але росіяни встигли
пристосуватися до цього саме леопарди
зараз
вони роблять дуже хороший вогневий вал і
дуже допомагають цим піхотів для
подальшого просування наземних
сухопутних сил ну дивіться як було на
початку наступу росіяни дуже викатували
на
заподію нам свої танки і так як леопарди
майже всіх нищили вони перестали це
робити вони дуже мало викатують свою
техніку вони бояться леопардів вони з
лопатою борються іншими способами
засобами
тепер вони використовують безпілотники
Міністерство оборони Росії є стверджує
що це відео зняти на початку цього літа
показує атаку на українській танк за
допомогою безпілотника ланцет українці
кажуть що леопарди зарекомендували себе
на полі бою вони швидкі можуть стріляти
далі І безпечніші за екіпажі танків
радянської конструкції які були до цього
але здається вони створюють проблеми
коли справа стосується технічного
обслуговування та особливо ремонту
артемі його команда можуть виконувати
певні ремонтні роботи на місці проте
каже що часто їм потрібен ремонт
гусениць танка найчастіше це у нас ідуть
під заміну резинки вони Ну вони дуже
швидко зношуються і катки гума дуже
швидко відлітає часто нам приходиться
міняти катки заказувати нові і
технічне обслуговування це одне а от
усунення пошкоджень набагато серйозніше
складніші пошкодження доводиться усувати
на заводах за межами України один із
таких запрацював на території Польщі Це
завод Бумер лабенди углевицях де
відкрили центр технічного обслуговування
та ремонту отриманих Україною танків
Леопард 2а4
на початку
ми на початку цієї дороги йдеться про
ремонт і перевірку танків для
української армії наразі ми прийняли 5
таких танків ми на етапі завершення
ремонту та перевірки перших двох і це
поки що початок цього шляху
наразі
спочатку танки проходять повний огляд
далі їх
ремонту лише після цього леопарди
відправляють назад в Україну
вони вже на завершальній стадії
підготовки до покриття та підготовки
танку до випробувань перед передачею
замовнику якщо ми трохи посунемося в
цьому напрямку ми побачимо інші машини
які все ще перебувають на перевірці це
там де машини все ще накриті там вежа та
шасі все ще на перевірці
якби в тракторі верифікації ці танки
брали участь у голубих діях в Україні
під час повномасштабного вторгнення тому
мають ряд проблем кажуть працівники
починаючи від проблем з гарматами якими
бачимо з іншого боку так само і тут
двигун пішов на перевірку та
доопрацювання щоб усунути витікання
з реалізацією що стосується питань
ремонту шасі то тут також і йде
завершення повного капітального ремонту
леопард-2 А4
2 а4
перевіряємо пускові установки домових
гранатометів українці мабуть
користуються ними щодня І вони вже
врятували життя не одній людині
і стволи які зношуються через різного
роду боєприпаси якими стріляють українці
такі ремонти за межами України можуть
вивести танк з бойових дій на Місяці
інша проблема броня у леопарда 2 а4 вона
легша ніж у радянських бойових танків
величезні міні-поля встановлені
росіянами уповільнюють Контрнаступ ці
військові відчули це на власному досвіді
на одному танку ми вже подарувались на
міні
У нас контужений Екіпаж
ми його відремонтували після того як ми
там були в лікарні все-таки Ми
відремонтували поміняли нам все що там
треба
тому військові сподіваються майбутньому
отримати танки з кращою бронею незабаром
вони повернуться на передову щоб ночами
знову захищати від ворога